citizens of the reject Nation it's me Tara
Erickson alongside this guy it was just his
birthday Eva turned 45. everybody get in the
chat be like Happy 45th birthday old jokes
are only about you I know but like I switched
it it's like a switch in Reverse for today
no I cannot take it he can't he can't a woman
can take you are programmed to be strong and
belittled by men not I have Mom issues and
now you have triggered all that good luck
because his walls are not as strong as mine
and we are watching How to Train Your Dragon
too so we both might cry you said that people
said that it's like a better one for a thing
and we don't know I'm not 100 confident I've
seen this one but I think I have I have not
I I've only heard the Train Your Dragon 2
is also very very good trilogies the whole
trilogy is amazing you called it I forget
what you called it coming of Christ headache
okay guys don't forget you gotta leave a like
yeah you gotta get in there you gotta comment
you also have to ring that foreign
reactions the whole entire thing is on patreon
so you got to get up get in there get super
sexy because we call you super sexy rejects
when you get on the patreon so join up you'll
see all their full-long reactions watch alongs
all that as well as this one as well as this
one exclusively over there yeah we do too
we all have a little page here for Tara to
read and uh I just figured I'm sitting here
that you guys know but this video hopefully
the editors will switch that around don't
forget don't forget that this video with me
and Greg can be seen on patreon okay sync
up with your own copy and watch along the
whole entire movie I think we're ready to
watch the Dragon movie are you yeah I think
the three minute intro is good enough yeah
[Music] you see where most folks enjoy Hobbies
like whittling or needlepoint we burkeyans
prefer oh we like to call
Dragon Racing oh fun that's what they're doing
now cool here you go babe can I tell you that
you look amazing today because you do come
on barf starting to stink around here nope
still hates you was he into her in the last
one I don't remember the guy who was just
talking I don't remember him but I remember
the other two they're gonna win now whatever
she wants she gets didn't she try to bury
you alive only for a few hours hey that's
that's flirting we have custom Stables all
you can eat feeding stations a full-service
Dragon wash how fun
the black sheep come on I love animation sequels
it's always so much more refined yeah I feel
like this one looks even more like sharper
sharpness yes the sharpness of the images
like moment have a nice flight I'm like these
sheep have to be like I hate this game yeah
oh yes yes here you go darling mine's worth
I'm totally winning we're winning together
we're attached genius quit trying to steal
all my glory Astrid you are so cool no sheep
no glory Ah that's my future daughter-in-law
so they still dating or engaged now oh yeah
engaged
wow this this would get me so nauseous because
with Vikings on the backs of dragons the world
just got a whole lot bigger how so ah yeah
what's toothless doing where are we going
take us there oh cool oh my God what's the
upgrade here whoa his that's him in that costume
yeah damn look at him he's a professional
writer wow he also looks like he's ready for
some BDSM slightly I mean not in a weird way
I'm just saying this is a kids movie I know
but I'm just like what's up with the thing
like the it's a lot maybe he's ready for medieval
times I should say but sometimes I get the
two confused [Laughter] so what do you think
Bud he's got a pumpkin oh does he what on
his shoulder pad I love everything about who
he has become since he lost a little bit of
his leg and got a dragon oh he's free-falling
awesome
how cool oh no way that is so cool
suit oh my God he invented squirrel suits
I just got goosebumps you guys and I'm not
joking [__] oh my goodness
how inventive amazing how inventive that's
so cool personal hot air balloon
okay I like that I like that showing you that
they don't have it completely together yet
right that there's still some obstacles to
overcome but I love how creative they're getting
with the aerodynamic stuff man hey handsome
do they age him of yeah he looks older absolutely
[Music] oh pretty ah looks like we found another
one bud oh what do you want an apology apology
oh my God it's so cute I can't see oh wow
you know that doesn't wash out [Music] that
laugh this is so great I didn't even think
about the amount of exploring you could do
now that you have a truck oh yeah like he
oh he's like building a map that's why he
said we found it that's awesome I think we
might find a few Timberjacks in those woods
maybe we'll finally track down another night
fury oh his family oh my God then you could
have baby night fairies and sell the night
furies or just keep them all forever nope
monetization
winning races what else
I signed her down to breakfast thinking all
is right with the world and I get son we need
to talk not now
and since no Chief could ask for a better
successor I've decided thank you chief
God he doesn't want it all those speeches
and planning and running the village that's
his thing you're a leader I you know exactly
who you are you always have but I'm still
looking I love this attention to detail of
the animals rough playing together yeah but
I'm not my father and I never met my mother
so what does that make me why do you need
to have met your mother to know who you are
what you're searching for isn't out there
it's in here maybe you just don't see it yet
great attention to detail it doesn't wash
off
Oh I thought it's burning
[Music]
Heroes afloat
whoa it really stands out in this environment
are we about to meet the villain of this story
it looks like it protruded from within the
water like yeah it does it was like a big
oh is it like oh like ice mixed with like
a a rack magic yeah magic pick up
oh what are they doing oh no sir what is going
on they came here to check up on you if you
hurt that Dragon you all die
oh this is so cruel no I hate it
Papa what is whoa uh they're Dragon Hunters
look we don't want any trouble he should have
thought of that before you stole all of our
dragons and blasted our Fort to [__]
so they do they tame Dragons Dragon trapping
it's hard enough work as it is without Duke
of Dragon Riders sneaking in to rescue them
there are other Dragon Riders you mean other
than your thieving friend from last night
you tell me deceiving friend he's expecting
a new shipment of dragons for his army by
tomorrow this is what he gave me last time
I showed up empty-handed that's that BDSM
you were talking about foreign [Music]
finest dragon trap were a lie it's not just
anyone who can capture a Night Fury no what
no oh [__] oh good job toothless
yeah yeah yeah go go that sucks they came
here to check up to see if people needed help
Drogo is coming for them all right you think
that's his real name Drago yeah just happens
it's absolutely one letter yeah yes I think
it was a choice yeah probably flown off the
edge of the world by now do you want that
kid running the village you can still delay
your retirement oh oh cool upgrades they probably
think they're like impenetrable with the amount
of dragons they have like completely unaware
yeah yes like that yeah yeah well they also
never knew that there were other Dragon Riders
out there this is actually a little more important
than building Saddles ah lesson two no task
is too small when it comes to sell finger
people
his dad still is the problem of not listening
very well yeah these guys Dragon Trappers
are gonna get yourselves Insidious trouble
one of these days
it's a really funny physical comedies they
are building a dragon Army Dargo bloody Fester
something it's not hard to remember the name
Dragon oh I think stoic knows who this guy
is fist
wait what is happening and this one has like
a menace to it was like a like a Darkness
yeah yeah it really like feels like it's coming
to the surface we can't wait around for him
to get here let's go find him and change his
mind yeah change his mind back is what you
need to worry about I takes his own nope you
gotta switch it up I don't want to see the
other dragons die I really don't I can't even
not war please no oh good job he's gonna just
go maybe he can change his mind the power
of communication yeah man we don't need to
go to war go get it Ingrid oh I don't think
it's Ingrid oh it's not what's her name you
called her Ingrid I thought it was Astrid
oh [__] or maybe you actually did call
her Astrid and I've been calling her Ingrid
is it Ingrid no I'm confused now I'm ready
I think it's we don't know it's the blonde
girl that's his girlfriend names are not our
specialty they're really not
going away this time no no they were prepared
we give up stay
what the show they'll just hang out with you
they won't be any trouble unless you do that
Wooden Boats big ocean how is your swimming
not good the guy seemed sad about his bad
swimming can't have armed Prisoners the other
sprays hideous sippleback gas spark and oh
oh once they see you as one of their own even
the testiest dragons can be trained oh oh
he's being clever what game are you playing
trying to show that you can Bond I go oh good
job dragon go fast
you won't be changing any Minds around here
I can change yours may I what what just happened
oh is that Stoke shocks they got him put me
down it's not loud what are you doing oh yeah
yeah got it I think they're saving him okay
[Music] oh no oh my God no you do not you
oh my God
of all the irresponsible I'm trying to protect
our dragons and stop a war how is that irresponsible
because war is what you want son but he's
trying years ago there was a gathering of
Chief dragon skills skirt yes I remember came
a stranger from a Strange Land covered in
scars and draped in a cloak of dragon skin
picture dragon skin was a man of the people
he claimed that he alone could control the
dragons and the he alone could keep us safe
if we chose to bow down oh I like how he's
narrating and you can still hear the undertones
of Drago's speech you can't hear him conveying
it until he robbed himself in his cloak and
cried now and see how well you do without
me
suddenly burst into flames from it armored
dragons descended holy I was the only one
to escape you need to toughen up your own
dragons this is what's gonna happen don't
worry bud I'm not gonna let anything happen
to you I promise I'm a God if anything happens
to toothless I'm gonna be a wreck so we just
don't even don't even what Grace what is that
that looks so spooky oh thank you
the hell what are we in a haunted house right
now
[Music] this music sounds heroic though
[Music] no get back up fly out fly no no no
no no no no I don't want to see toothless
suffer I can't I can't at all I'm like don't
let this be this kind of movie I can't handle
it my heart cannot handle this [Music] what
is that what is that no uh
uh what the hell is going on what's what is
this can are we gonna reveal that toothless
can breathe underwater it better be that [Music]
the music's throwing me off it sounds like
positive the music
[Applause] you're so cool hiccup you're such
a dweeb in the last movie he's a full-grown
teenager now who are you yeah thank you the
dragon Thief Drago blood fist this person
seems so Savage is that toothless voice oh
thank God save toothless okay [Music] oh this
person's good oh this person's real good oh
this person's at the height of their dragon
training
okay is it a person
the person who's is it just humanoid oh my
God oh my God oh it's a better trainer than
him another trainer is it his mom um that's
a great guess oh my God is it haircut I think
you're right
she know she just knows his face can I know
you you're only a babe but a mother never
forgets I I knew it what the hell what she's
just like a massive Dragon Tamer too what
are the odds he had it in his blood he never
knew it that's why he denied his dad's like
side of being a viking so much because he
had his mama side in him [Music] all right
these movies are directed so well like the
framing is so good that in his hands though
it looks so tiny in his dad's hands like like
it's rare you watch an animated movie where
you get a sense of the camera everyone thinks
you were eaten bye uh does she have a dragon
world
she's got oh my God she's been like breeding
amazing dragons and taking care of them
[Music]
this looks straight up like Avatar that's
so pretty yeah the last one had an avatar-esque
this right here Avatar exactly this is where
you've been for 20 years you've been rescuing
them interesting so she's like a little sort
of language barrier or she's like socially
off here I'm not sure maybe it might very
well be the last of his kind oh look he's
your age your age
did Drago or his Choppers do this too I'm
actually the one who shot him down maybe that's
why she couldn't go back because his dad is
still Viking and wanted to kill the dragons
remember
he changed they all did they were only it
were possible it is possible I tried as well
but people are not capable of change hiccup
oh that is the theme of this whole movie
wow that's a hell of a transition into a flashback
yeah Burke was a land of kill or be killed
but I believed peace was possible oh no no
no you'll only make it worse [Music] it was
a very unpopular opinion a dragon broke into
our house finding you in the Cradle oh interesting
oh he's always had a connection
proof of every firmed her belief oh I got
goosebumps
two um OED Mark yeah that I always wondered
what that Mark was on his chin an intelligent
gentle creature whose Soul reflected my own
no did they oh my God yeah no
[Applause] oh they grabbed her okay you and
your father nearly died that night all because
I couldn't kill a dragon ah it runs in the
family this is a touching ass movie how did
you survive oh Cloud Jumper never meant to
harm me he must have thought I belonged here
in the home of the great bewilder beast wowie
Kate Blanchette that's her name is
yes actress in tart that is so her voice very
few that still exist but he's icy breath this
graceful giant built our Nest ah cool he's
responsible for all that destruction he protects
us we all live under his care oh and this
has come on yeah wow this feels like truly
like a legendary oh
wow I feel like I'm watching a video game
holy crap I lived among
[Music] them wow the scale oh
[Laughter] it doesn't matter what dragon you
show me none are gonna be toothless he's the
cutest one of all
yeah you're gonna show us the way to dragon
and help Dragon ride is sneaking to Drago's
Camp just kill me now that could be arranged
God who is that voice though [Music]
Rihanna Stormfly is very good at fetching
wow this one is so like not just visually
but emotionally it's just like so sweeping
yeah it's very transportive wow whoa
oh my God oh my goodness oh he gets a fish
and he gives it to him in the air that's awesome
he's like Jesus like you said it's a second
coming up
Feast toothless [Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
yeah like it's communicating so much without
dialogue yeah the first one did that too like
when it was just it showed us more than it
told to us and this is doing the same but
in like yeah this is like Epic
detail on the physics is so impressive this
is what it is to be a dragon hiccup but can
you fly
laughs
[Laughter]
you gotta start burning into the situation
man yeah you've done that a few times
took after me yeah I'm so sorry hiccup will
you give me another chance one's so moving
I can teach you all that I've learned these
past 20 years oh so he must be 20. oh wow
do you know about this oh my God oh my goodness
she bought a video game upgrade we will change
the world for all dragons that sounds amazing
but you still got your dad to contend with
and Chief and Burke and also 20 years of like
psychological damage yeah that too you need
therapy man there's no talking to Drago but
we have no we must protect our own there's
still a stubbornness and uh lack of belief
in people that's what makes hiccup the the
linchpin though yeah it makes him the one
that is actually going to change it because
he he starts with belief system he wants to
communicate
down there a bunch of dragon bones that's
for sure
oh no [Music]
damn how powerful are those darts this build
up to drag go bad for almost an hour in still
haven't seen him
we just saw him
you're welcome hmm he's he's Maui he does
look a lot like Maui as you can see I am right
on time with a new batch of dragons just like
I promised is that kit Harrington who was
just talking yeah the the doofus one I have
to hear him again I don't think so what what
just happened what oh yeah dragon scale dragon
skin
all right jeez if you so much just touch us
hiccup is gonna kick he's only the son of
stoic the vast and the greatest Dragon Master
this world has ever seen I know you're trying
to be threatening but you might be giving
too much information also stand back we must
attack the Dragon Riders less than once take
down their offer then we will take and this
guy is menacing please
oh protected him
I hate these darts it's interesting seeing
Drago and his mom and like two different versions
of tribal kind of people yeah how did you
get in here see we were getting you out come
on wait okay uh dad that there's something
you need to know yeah tell me all the way
your wife lives here ex-wife you may want
to take this
I know what you're gonna say stoic stayed
away all of these years and why didn't I come
back to you what sign did I have that you
could change wow this is why I never married
I spent one other reason
I'm better off without me I was wrong Shout
Scream say something
as a family now newly reunited they will have
to take drug go down and also save this no
name guys this guy's totally defecting Signs
Now our friend you are a steaming heap of
dragon duck yeah cool oh he's not a doofus
oh
this help he's capable when the moment calls
for it love it so we're going to save your
dragons and get out of here okay now I really
think it's Kit Harington yeah I need to listen
when he speaks I haven't been I just hear
him thank you saving my life
okay I listen then you might be right it might
be yeah I'm a on board kit Harrington I think
I don't know you wouldn't believe how much
Everything's changed your son's changed built
for the better I think we did well with this
one though I think he's just like just as
comfortable as always huh he scared her and
she dropped the fish sir once you move back
in with all your dragons oh Drago won't even
stand a chance she's not gonna move back in
this is her home and she likes it here
might Sail On Savage sea
[Music] he he oh he's always had a soft side
home [Music]
and the music in this one is so good yeah
it really feels like they're building out
a culture yeah like now that they're back
together the family crest would look different
yeah yeah
toothless always pushing his agendas but she
has a home yes oh wow wait but who's going
to stay there and take care of all the dragon
stuff what's happening
oh my God it's gonna blow up their whole home
we have to save the dragons Come On Son
I mean they got a big Alice Alpha dragon on
their hand yeah they do that's true that big
ass snow dragon
wow what a tracking shot oh man keep it hitting
the mountain you need to draw the alpha out
always that's right specifically haunting
the alpha yeah man oh man but if he gets tame
the alpha they'll be about nulls
[Applause] haha cool
yes nice take him down
oh yeah Dad's gonna have to come face Drago
where where have you been catching up with
Mom
that is something special oh my God it's amazing
I mean I know they haven't been murdering
any of the humans but at least go for Drago
damn all right whoa
attic boy
I don't know I feel like something terrible
is about to happen yeah I really don't want
Mom to die you cannot take out dragons they
aren't controlled by the ocean I brought a
Challenger
that scream is terrifying oh he's got an alpha
of his own oh great
that's like actually scary the light and the
dark side how about that texture looks whoa
what is that oh my goodness
oh God no we're not gonna do this are we
haha
is she gonna be able to tame this black snow
dragon I mean I think they just gotta defeat
it yeah
the way they capture the scope of this is
very impressive
[Music]
yeah did they just kill the alpha I don't
like it [Music]
and now they think he's the alpha oh God
no oh my God no no no no no no no no no no
I did not expect that to happen me neither
all right let's get to these big ass dragons
really feels like a monster movie all of this
loss
to rule the world kind amazing creatures that
can bring people together tear them apart
oh he's like the super dark version of Hiccup
yeah the world wants peace
that scream is just rooted in so much torment
man no dragon can resist the Alpha's command
he who controls
[Music]
no no no hiccup do the juice do something
I hate this toothless oh my God oh my God
oh [__] snap out of it
oh no oh no
no
ah dad stoic
[Music]
a haircut doesn't even know what he did
now get away from him no no he didn't know
oh no no he didn't know
it's not his fault you know that
good dragons under the control of bad people
do bad things that's really that's so sad
oh my God God I hate it
what the hell man this one's this is rough
like this is like really tough for me emotional
goddamn like really putting their audience
to test your pen is you hate this movie right
now if you just keeping like it's gonna end
on such a sad dark note yeah may they sing
your name with love and fury I know that you've
taken your rightful place at the table of
Kings so he has to be the leader now
foreign
like Blown Away by how mature this one is
yeah it's like so mature now we don't have
to regret my BDSM because there's nowhere
near what just happened not the Peacekeeper
I thought I was
oh what a shot it was such a wee thing a feared
you wouldn't make it but your father he never
doubted always said you'd become the strongest
of them all
you have the heart of a chief and the soul
of a dragon only you can bring our worlds
together jeez that is who you are son
it's like The Lion King I was so afraid of
becoming my dad or a beautiful shot how do
you become someone that great that Brave that
selfless I guess you can only try it's that
fight a chief protects his own we're going
back uh he took all the dragons not all of
them what well
okay oh like the baby ones just take control
of these guys too they're babies they don't
listen to anyone [Music] goodness is this
Drago just destroying the whole thing
I feel like I haven't seen her the whole movie
where are you going
horrifying feels like a Kaiju monster the
way they captured it that's true mythological
creature
[Music] God uh I'm totally blinking the kind
of Norse mythology yeah oh yeah hey look it's
hiccup [Applause]
still the leader that rises to the occasion
oh I just realized he's writing hiccup what
a dick move no he's writing he's writing toothlessly
imagine if he was right a hiccup that would
look really good
[Music]
you certainly are hard to get rid of Toothless
poor toothless it's me it's me I'm right here
come back to me oh try to take him he will
not miss a second time it wasn't your fault
but oh
you'd never hurt him
man this movie oh boy
you are my best friend bud
and a boy that's it oh you jerk
hang on oh he's down for it
[Music]
we need to get those two apart
trust me bud
you and me oh whoa
that's it oh the mom said this is what it
means to be a dragon yeah
shut it out toothless stop them now whoa
ah
now or never
come on buddy he could do it yes wow
it's all over now or is it
uh what [Music] check up
oh is it night Fury's like stuff going yeah
yeah
oh my God
[Music]
he's challenging the alpha to protect you
wow [Music] oh my God
oh everyone's everyone's snapping at us
right right you suck man yeah like you really
oh my God so much this is what it is to earn
a dragon's loyalty let this end now never
oh buddy I know man should have just said
okay but Night Fury knows who Night Fury is
with all those things on his back now so you
better watch out
right now
oh man nice job toothless iron the nature
oh [__] oh scariest protects them all
right oh my gosh
no my little guy yeah he's just right back
to being his little sweet precious thing
[Music]
more Regal
I don't feel like I'm watching an animated
care I feel like I'm really watching like
animals
[Laughter]
[Music] not you
you'd make a good Chopper Skull Crushers you
need somebody to look after him now no no
way yeah that's what makes you a leader man
your father it'd be every bit as proud as
I am thank you I'm really glad you're here
Mom wow what they've done with this hiccup
character is phenomenal yeah
oh yes oh make it official
the chief has come home hmm
wow this is Burger
oh hell yeah awesome we will change this world
[Applause]
oh sure they have armies and they have armadas
but we we have how he's playing with them
our dragons
our dragons oh my god wow this movie is perfect
I thought that was so moving holy junk I've
never been so angry and then also very like
five minutes later burst into tears during
a movie I was so mad like oh my God please
don't do this to us but wow there's so much
that happened it's based on a book series
totally didn't catch that prior I guess let's
get some names really quick you were damn
you nailed that Tara yeah man you nailed that
it's Kate man I did not catch Kate Blanchett
I can hear her from a mile away I didn't know
that ass yeah I was wrong because I was calling
Ingrid I don't know where I got that from
uh I didn't know it was an is America Ferrara
but I know she was in the first one I just
whatever there was jeremon it was Kit Harington
okay yeah I got them both right nailed it
oh my God this is a perfect movie I love it
so much the first one is like so amazing and
great yes and never did I think that I would
be like how did they do better completely
surpass what was already an incredible film
yeah wow they and and it's not like it's I'm
I'm I I I remember an element one little thing
about the third movie trailer so I I know
one tiny thing just from the trailer and I
think it's on the cover so that's why I think
I remember it oh um so I'm like okay I know
where it can go but if I didn't have that
image in my head I would go where do you go
from here because this is like so complete
it's such a complete film absolutely whereas
you know um it doesn't end in a way where
it's like oh we're setting up a third one
or something like that okay so to me I'm just
so I'm so dazzled by this one I found it so
impressive and it was so emotional while since
I've seen uh an animated movie that had me
that emotional this might be this is like
this is gonna be like a top five top three
animated movie for me the specifically this
one yeah yeah I mean the the emotions that
they put the audience through is insane uh
I I mean even in the first one I felt like
they it was wrapped up in a pretty bow slightly
afterwards but we wanted to see more of the
story of you know Hiccup and Toothless after
they both lost their legs how did their relationship
grow and like boy oh boy did we see it but
also I love that like they gave him the mark
in the beginning I didn't know it was off
obviously they all they read all the books
and made these movies like the markanish 10
but like learning all of that the relationship
about what happened and and his mom is like
it's awesome also why does she look so cool
like her costuming which they're still costuming
an animation uh amazing uh and for us to learn
that that's where he got it from and that's
why his relation in the beginning with his
dad was difficult and we learned that he got
a lot of his heart and his Dragon stuff from
his mom which was nice to see um but also
the struggles that they had to go through
like in being reconnected as a family and
then being ripped apart like oh it happened
so fast the the first movies yeah it does
happen really quick when you think about the
time frame of that because at that moment
I was like go either way the mom could die
or the dad or the dad yeah either either or
right now um because the first movie ends
where we're like okay Burke is gonna Embrace
dragons and this movie really Embraces the
world that it is now because like the dragons
are such a prevalent part of experiencing
um the bonding and the kinship of like a communal
experience of of having dragons right you
know as it was in the first movie it's just
Hiccup and Toothless and then here you're
getting this there's a whole new kind of world
expansion on all kinds where you got the the
completely malevolent side and and then you
have the side with them on the benevolent
side of it you know um where all these characters
have their their trauma and you're watching
how it all sort of plays out and manifests
and I I think the the parallels they draw
this these themes about you know the willingness
to change and the power that can come from
Humanity of within and like The Power of Choice
so I I I was so dazzled and moved like there's
such a as much as there's the dragon experience
or such a human experience yeah um that they
that they flesh out so well like they never
lose sight of their character-driven narrative
one bit it is the the driving force of this
movie you know because like yeah with Hiccup
and his mom when I first came to to be there
was that tiny cynical part of my brain that
was like how's it going to play out it's gonna
be goofy yeah but then the way she behaves
where he does describers like kind of like
a a feral woman which she said seemed a little
socially awkward because she hasn't been around
he was like man the attention to detail on
this portrayal is so good because she does
seem a little bit off yes she does seem a
little bit odd and that she's someone who's
just been living with dragons and not interacting
with people you know I I love that um and
the relationship that she forms where you
you see how they get past um the hardship
really quick and it was so beautiful I was
finding myself V moved to Tears by just how
beautiful things were and then of course when
things got really sad and tragic and then
hopeful like it was kind of that all-around
tears experience yeah and then even when you
know uh stoic reunites with her how that doesn't
go down this cliche path that was there's
just so much like this pain underneath the
surface yeah that where there where there's
this Conquest for of love that I think that's
the thing that always moves me is when you
fight Against All Odds but with the power
of love as corny as that [__] sounds I'm
like that's the stuff that really moves me
you know I thought he was gonna say but we
have love at the end like love and Dragons
yeah um because I felt like that's what is
like the foundation of the story especially
like you said like you do feel there's still
an underneath Foundation of like pain that
was experienced with the mom and the dad when
they reunite and then it opens up that really
relationship when he starts whistling and
singing the song that they both remembered
and I I like that hiccup had that experience
to see that it wasn't so tragic after all
it was terrible that Mom could be around but
it was explained sure there was a little bit
that we needed it didn't feel like Exposition
explained as to why she left um but then shown
how she sort of like fit back into the world
to build up his trust and enough it didn't
take all this stuff for the dad and the son
to trust her and for the dad to be like will
you come back home with us there wasn't like
a didn't need to be a big fight or any of
that he was just like I still love you great
she gave her explanation it happened pretty
quickly but it happened in a really believable
way that I it was so nice to see that hiccup
got to experience his parents like he never
was able to being like in love and as a force
and then was able to actually go and fight
with them and it didn't work out but he did
still get that experience for the rest of
his life which is it's great because he he
even says like I don't know if I'll ever know
anybody as like big and brave and like as
Fearless but like now he has you know his
mom on his side and he hasn't had a lot of
experience with her yet but she is the definition
also of that yeah it's interesting how the
movie Drew this kind of an unexpected visual
parallel between the mom and the villain Drago
because oh yeah you know like they're they're
the two who got the flashbacks yeah where
you I mean one was a flashback of the perspective
that stoic was having about him and then of
course how he tames and uses dragons like
it's very dictatorship it's Draconian in the
way he goes about it like he's he's evil yeah
but but he's also someone who's who has a
lot of hurt you know he's got a lot of people
hurt people people hurt people and and then
you draw the parallel with the mom who's also
like again kind of like trying tribal about
her her physicality and mannerisms and you
see the way her relationship is with the dragons
and then it's like these two this is like
a fight for Souls you know like the souls
within people um the quality of a soul right
and and you see that that's the thing that
truly forms the relationship with the dragons
I it's the last thing I expected them to do
because they're telling these these multiple
stories here and then they found this narrative
where they draw this parallel that you you
just don't see coming between the mom because
it's not that obvious they're not they're
not hitting you on overnight at all but it's
there it's in the movie it's it's a visual
represent representation of it it's the that's
where the two Alphas come head to head is
is from the mom's Alpha and and his Alpha
yeah uh and it's something I just did not
anticipate that this film I thought they were
just telling like okay we got the story of
Rodrigo new villain and now we got the story
with the mom okay and I guess those are gonna
fight at some point or like oh this is so
much deeper and more nuanced than uh I I could
have ever anticipated and even the handling
of like stoic dying I I I I expected them
when he died to okay he's injured there's
probably going to be some speech here oh there's
no speech no he's just dead like damn this
move is going for like so Fantastical yeah
it's so it's so like not realistic but it's
treating it with such great gravitas and realism
like yeah oh he just he's just dead yeah he
died right here and he died on the battlefield
and the way you would sort of expect to go
about it and and died protecting his son you
know uh probably the way he would want if
there's a way to go it would be this way you
know yeah and I feel like any other movie
like the speech would have came then but they
waited until you know they're they're doing
their whatever they're at the funeral right
they're shooting off and then me uh he finally
gives his speech of saying like he he doesn't
know that he'll know every anyone else that's
as Brave and it's fearless and all of that
yeah um which is the reason why I said oh
it's like Lion King because the Sun backdropped
that beautiful shot where he's like you go
see his back in the sun it's like yeah he
looks like Simba uh it just reminded me of
that of here he comes he's up and he's rising
and he um he did it also his way like he he
never had to um be like all compromise and
I'll help fight with you Dad and we're gonna
start off we'll do the war thing it was always
that he even with his mom it was still like
this is the way that I I see it should go
down um and uh I like that I I guess I just
really respect the gut punch of the realism
of the loss of stoic in that moment because
yeah rather than giving stoic some like dying
speech yeah that is how lost can go down in
the situation like that like it's so unexpected
so sudden you know yeah that's Rose really
that that like broke me well that is extra
broke me when he was like get away I was like
I started crying I was already crying I'm
about to scream stop because he didn't mean
it he didn't mean it and that hurt my heart
more than you know uh also because like he
had no idea he did it he didn't no he just
was like oh God it makes my stomach hurt even
talking about like that was what that movie
did to me like it makes me like uh physically
hurt when I think about it because they put
me in a situation where everything was so
beautiful and sharp and believable yeah uh
just like in the first one we made a lot of
comments about the voiceovers in this seems
so real and I kept saying I think they put
them in a room and make them move around like
I I'm like I wouldn't be surprised if they're
like here's a kind of a set move around as
you as you feel or it's all miked up in here
because this one made me feel the exact same
way like I'm just taken into this world and
there's nothing that brings me out of it not
even the comedic characters and in a lot of
live action they try to do the same thing
as this where then they're still like the
nerdy character who makes some jokes brings
some levity to a situation like right after
the I think the dad died it was like his friend
made like oh all right we're we're going down
here now I don't remember and it was like
it's a little light-hearted thing I didn't
mind it it didn't throw me off too much it
was one little piece of levity that fit in
and they didn't try too hard to like hit us
over the head with that to make it like oh
this is still a fun movie because they were
scared we would all be like well what we were
I was like I was mad I was angry and then
I was very sad but um those moments that brought
levity the situation um they were they were
great and everything was done in a real graceful
manner with like little tidbits that we needed
without drawing it out so much yeah they just
were like this is this is enough I think for
the movie we're gonna move on now and trust
us when it all comes together you will have
ridden through a roller coaster and been taken
through a journey of not feeling just for
one or two characters of really feeling for
a lot and each one of them I really thought
it was going to end shortly after stoic died
me too and I was like we're gonna end on like
a Darkness I was like yeah right and then
you're like now I have to watch three right
away otherwise I really thought that's where
we were going yeah me too um uh it's so impressive
what they've done with Hiccup like when you
think about his character in the first one
like you're really watching this guy grow
up not just physically yeah like he's he's
so maturing that if you were to look at who
he was in the first like even at the end of
the first movie he would become the leader
of the Vikings of the people of Burke yeah
I wouldn't be like I really I don't know about
that I'd be like he's a little too scared
he doesn't know he's a little too like uh
dorky yeah and they don't like they don't
like character assassinate they don't rewrite
him no they just let him grow let him grow
up that by the time he becomes the leader
and he's like not at all emulating the mannerisms
of his dad he's not trying to turn him into
his dad he's they're just letting him be his
own identity and you really believe him as
yes you are the leader yeah you are the right
person for this um they're letting him go
from being a boy really evolving into a man
yeah in a way that is insanely believable
for something that I again did not anticipate
that this movie would go down the route over
attempt to pull and then the evolution of
Hiccup um I mean God damn it um
um the evolution of two plus two is like he's
coming just like power set yeah uh they they
still keep that as the core of the even though
it's like it gets bigger and more Grand it's
not just about Toothless and Hiccup they still
keep it at the center yeah I agree like like
in what I said and kind of what you were saying
of like he did it on he did it still being
fully hiccup the entire time yeah and even
at the end he's still the hiccup we knew before
he's just now the leader that they all needed
but it's funny they both did need Mom and
even uh you know toothless obviously needed
mom to like bring out the scales on his back
that's the only reason he was able to do that
final move yeah with Hiccup at the very end
where you're like oh man that's awesome and
I also feel like a little bit of that it's
like toothless now became fully who he is
he was so excited when his mom found like
that and he was like oh they're here like
as though he forgot kind of and then that
that made him more powerful in that moment
but I also think maybe in that moment of like
he was now fully formed toothless right with
his you know owner being able to fight back
and through that ice that he right at the
very end where it's like oh man he he it's
like uh hiccup could only do so much and did
like almost like a hundred percent but I kind
of think like oh man like they both kind of
really needed mom to come through because
if mom hadn't known that like spot I don't
know if hiccup would have ever found it sure
and it really did bring toothless to life
I think in a lot of ways and it's really is
so exciting to see that Mom is there she's
now in the home and she's getting to finally
have that time with her son that she lost
for the 20 years in a world that now brought
the combination of her world where she was
living for 20 years along with her son's world
together because I thought when I saw the
sadness in her eyes when Dad was like do you
want to come back and live with us I thought
she was going to be like but my home is here
now and I take care of these dragons this
is the world I've lived here for 20 years
I really thought she might say that and then
she said yes she would come home so I'm sure
they would have figured it out but now in
seeing it I was like oh but she did get what
she wanted the dragons from her home came
to uh hiccup's home to Burke and now she she
gets that life which is really I mean I'll
love to see what three is it's such a good
story we got we gotta wrap it up we gotta
wrap it up listen the last thing I give it
nine out of ten ten out of ten I mean I don't
know 11 out of ten like out of everything
like it was all we talked about was the story
of characters yes the animation is [__]
Flawless oh yeah the animation yeah um the
animation is Flawless yeah I love the the
attention to detail and the physicality and
of course like there was I noticed there's
a lot more like motion happening in the background
like the environments that were lived in uh
music once again sweeping like all the technical
scale stuff is like it didn't feel like an
animated movie that's why I was like I don't
even need to comment on it this is such a
real movie I don't even see it as like truly
cinematic yeah like no one here I've seen
a good amount of animated [__] here and
this is like this is Top This is top this
is like the this is probably the best the
best the best one I've seen like personally
like reacted to it this might be the the best
one I've personally like watched I had a camera
pointed at me and watched it like no one's
saying you should watch How to Train Your
Dragon is ever gonna go it's an animated movie
and you do that with animated movies sometimes
I'm like this these movies you don't even
have to it doesn't even matter it's just saying
like this is a beautiful film and I the animation
doesn't even it's so good it doesn't even
it just clocks in my brain is a beautiful
movie yeah it's great 10 uh 11 stars out of
10. we love it tell us what you guys think
comment like you know do the deal we love
you so much and uh I'm tired from crying being
mad and crying but uh that's all that's all
we got we'll see you on the on the next one
we love you so much bye foreign